hier kennt man ihn kaum
doch in den usa ist er eine gewichtige
stimme
cornel west der afro amerikanische
philosoph kann sich mit einer ganzen
reihe von auszeichnungen und orden
schmücken war professor an den besten
universitäten amerika sie ale harvard
princeton
doch das leben im elfenbeinturm behagt
dem umtriebigen mann nicht stattdessen
zettelte er immer wieder protestaktionen
an spielt hip hop alben ein und tritt in
talkshows auf
das ziel des public intellectuals ist
seit seiner jugend dasselbe
der kampf gegen rassismus und für ein
demokratisches amerika mit präsident
obama übrigens geht er hart ins gericht
bauer fleisch hat cornel west in
hannover getroffen
cornel west 2008 hat präsident obama zum
ersten mal für die präsidentschaft
kandidiert damals haben sie ihn
tatkräftig unterstützt heute sagen sie
er ist eine enttäuschung sie kritisieren
was ist passiert
ich hatte keine ahnung dass er ein wall
street präsident werden würde ein
drohnen präsident ein präsident der
nationalen überwachung ein präsident der
die wall street anstatt die
hauseigentümer rettet er bombardiert
unschuldige 221 kinder in somalia jemen
und pakistan wurden so getötet
er weise den nationalen sicherheit statt
aus und verletzt die freiheiten und
rechte nicht nur der us bürger sondern
der menschen weltweit als ich 65
veranstaltungen zu seiner unterstützung
organisiert wusste ich nicht dass er
sich so klar auf die seite der eliten
stellen würde
anstatt die armen und die arbeiterklasse
zu unterstützen
sie nennen ihn manchmal das schwarze
maskottchen der wallstreet oligarchen
und sie nennen ihn auch einen
kriegsverbrecher gehen sie damit nicht
ein bisschen zu weit
ich sage einfach die wahrheit ich
entstamme der tradition von martin
luther king junior und fans
ich nannte george bush einen
kriegsverbrecher als er 45 drohnen vom
auf unschuldige werfen ließ ich bin für
moralische gleichheit
also erwarte ich dasselbe von einem
schwarzen einem weißen oder sonst einen
präsidenten
wenn ich sage obama sei ein
kriegsverbrecher meine ich mehr
unschuldige zivilisten tötet muss sich
dafür verantworten
das gilt für jeden präsidenten in jeder
nation wie viel kann in einen präsident
ihrer meinung nach überhaupt ausrichten
ein problem ist ja natürlich dass er
nicht alleine ist hat diese ganzen
politiker hinten dran
der kongress sagt man ist auf blockiert
also ist ihre ehre ihr vorwurf an obama
wirklich gerechtfertigt
es kommt auf die thematik im weißen haus
wird zb jeden dienstag aufgrund einer
todesliste entschieden wen sie töten
werden und ist jetzt haben sie vier
amerikaner getötet und mussten sich
dafür nicht verantworten
sie verhaften ohne gerichtsverfahren
morden ohne rechenschaftspflicht es gibt
strukturen und institutionelle
verpflichtungen aber es werden
entscheidungen getroffen
nicht nur von obama auch von
außenministerin hillary clinton und von
vize präsident joe biden
es stimmt alle präsidenten unterliegen
strukturellen zwängen sie haben
tötungsmaschinen in druck der wall
street aber ich finde progressive
politiker sollten sich vor allem um die
armen und die arbeitenden bürger kümmern
momentan ist das in den usa schlicht
nicht der fall
wenn er sie fragen würde was muss ich
tun um sie wieder zu überzeugen was wäre
so ein statement oder eine einen
beschluss den erfassen könnte für den
sie dann denken würden doch da hat er
jetzt wirklich etwas erreicht was mich
überzeugt ich denke seinen fokus sollte
die ausrottung der armut seien zudem
müsste er die qualität von erziehung und
bildung fördern anstatt zu erlauben das
durch wachsende privatisierung profit
aus der öffentlichen bildung geschlagen
wird er sollte dem beispiel von finnland
und anderen skandinavischen ländern
folgen und sagen die bildung muss das
juwel in unserer krone sein das heißt in
seinem fokus sollten die jugendlichen
seien
heute leben in den usa 22 prozent der
jungen menschen in armut 40 prozent der
farbigen kinder sind arm und das in der
reichsten nationen der welt das finde
ich obszön und gottlos und dagegen wird
nichts getan
das gleiche gilt für den neuen jim crow
was sich in einer regelrechten gefängnis
industrie äußert wir haben 2,5 millionen
häftling in den usa 60 prozent von ihnen
sitzen wegen weicher drogen nicht wegen
mord oder vergewaltigung in den usa sind
zwölf prozent der schwarzen und zwölf
prozent der weißen kinder drogenabhängig
65 prozent der deswegen verurteilten
sind schwarz der rassismus im
strafrechtssystem sitzt tief das ist
falsch das thema training einem ihrer
vielen forschungsgebiete die sie haben
nämlich rassismus in den usa sie haben
den neuen jim crow erwähnt das ist ja
eigentlich eine figur synchro ist eine
figur die den titel gegeben hat für eine
ganze reihe von rassengesetzen die bis
1964 in den usa die rassentrennung
vorgeschrieben haben jim crow ist
angesehen hier im bild ist eine figur
mit dem man sich lächerlich gemacht hat
lustig gemacht hat über ein stereotyp
ein rassistisches stereotyp vom blatt
people und heute sagt man diese gesetze
die sind eigentlich wieder ankommen zwar
nicht gesetze in engeren sinn aber in
institutioneller ungerechtigkeit findet
man diesen yu jing pro haben ein paar
beispiele gegeben kann es noch ein
bisschen
ausführen was sie damit genau meinen
dass dieser tim krohn wieder stattfindet
in den usa ich denke wir müssen mit der
rolle der weißen vorherrschaft in der
modernen welt beginnen in europa hängt
sie mit dem kolonialismus in afrika und
asien zusammen die briten
kolonialisierten indien die belgier den
kongo und so weiter in den usa sind es
die land enteignungen der indigenen
völker und die versklavung der afrikaner
in den usa betrieben die weißen 244
jahrelang sklaverei dann hat mir einen
barbarischen bürgerkrieg 750.000 tote
darauf folgten zwölf jahre demokratie
unter beteiligung verschiedener rassen
und dann kamen die gemco gesetze und
somit eine neue form von sklaverei und
weißer vorherrschaft
mit welchem ziel um menschen zu
terrorisieren zu traumatisieren und zu
stigmatisieren
der europäische imperialismus tat das
gleiche weise über machten den usa oder
die vereinigten staaten als ein
imperiales projekt gesehen stochern
weiter in den wunden und narben der
ureinwohner der hispanics der farbigen
und schwarzen zum neuen gott sei dank
haben die bürgerrechtsbewegung und
andere organisationen den schwarzen
rechte und freiheiten verschafft aber
gegen arme schwarze und gegen die
schwarze arbeiterklasse geht der staat
immer noch sehr repressiv vor mit massen
inhaftierungen und massiven verletzungen
ihrer rechte und freiheiten lassen thema
bleibt vor allem bezüglich der armen
schwarzen und der schwarzen
arbeiterklasse
das gilt in gewisser hinsicht auch für
andere hautfarben aber vor allem die
schwarzen sind in einem neuen jim crow
system gefangen
wir könnten sagen früher war es tim
kruse
heute ist das jim crow juni ein beispiel
das auch hierzulande viel diskutiert
worden ist sich die stop und frisst
politik dass man sozusagen in den
straßen new yorks menschen einfacher
anhalten darf durchsuchen darf die
polizei
darf einfach auf verdacht hin leute
sozusagen anfassen und untersuchen und
schauen ob sie drogen mit sich tragen
und dass man gesehen habt zu einem sehr
sehr hohen prozentsatz sind das vor
allem eben dunkelhäutige menschen die da
angegangen werden und das ist glaube ich
auch so ein beispiel wo sie gesagt haben
das ist der neue
das ist ein gutes beispiel ist aber ich
denke dass haben viele nicht gemerkt
über vier millionen junge farbige und
schwarze männer wurden in den letzten
achteinhalb jahren in new york city
unter bürgermeister bloomberg durch
diese stop and risk praxis angehalten
und durchsucht
karl dix und dich riefen zum protest auf
natürlich wurden verhaftet kamen ins
gefängnis und wurden nach einer wöchigen
gerichtsverhandlung schuldig gesprochen
wir taten es aus einem wesentlichen
grund wir wollten den armen jugendlichen
zu verstehen geben dass wir sie lieben
wir gingen für sie ins gefängnis und die
elite in new york city zu zwingen die
menschenwürde dieser jugendlichen zu
respektieren und anzuerkennen dass die
verletzung ihrer rechte falsch ist gott
sei dank hatten wir ein öffentliches
gespräch
der neue bürgermeister belde blasier
will dieses gesetz nicht abschaffen aber
zumindest zu ändern
stellen sie sich vor 1800 durchsuchte
pro tag und nur 15 prozent sind
kriminell aufgefallen 98 prozent wurden
einfach belästigt gedemütigt ihrer
rechte beraubt
das ist ein beweis für den repressiven
apparat des nationalstaats der es auf
arme jugendliche abgesehen hat vor allem
auf arme schwarze und farbige
jugendlichen eine debatte ausgelöst hat
ja auch die erschiessung von kevin
martin
dieser junge der von einem hispanischen
bürger erschossen wurde der
nachbarschaft polizist war sozusagen
und da gab es ja dann ein prozess er
wurde freigesprochen obwohl man vermutet
dass es ein
nicht ungerechtfertigt war und präsident
obama hat sich ja dann hingestellt nach
diesem urteil dass er eben frei
gesprochen wird und habe gesagt das
hätte mein sohn sein können
viele hat was sehr bewegt gerade auch
die aufräum ricanerin und afro
amerikaner
wie ging es ihnen es hat auch nicht
bewegt denn er hätte wirklich sein sohn
sein können aber dann fuhr er fort und
sagte er an die adresse des mörders
wir sind ein rechtsstaat respektieren
wir das gesetz wenn es um meinen sohn
ging ich habe einen sohn
wenn man meinen sohn ermordet hätte
würde ich nicht fordern dass das gesetz
respektiert wird sondern dass es
geändert wird denn mord ist falsch
amoralisch entmenschlicht und ungerecht
wenn ihr sohn ermordet wird ist ihre
erste reaktion nicht wir sind ein
rechtsstaat dass es kalt unbeteiligt und
distanziert wo ist die leidenschaft der
gerechte zorn die moralische entrüstung
wenn ihr einziger sohn wie ein hund
abgeknallt wird
daher überraschte mich obamas
distanziertheit in seiner aussage wir
sind ein rechtsstaat
[Musik]
gewisse gesetze sind falsch gewisse
gesetze rechtfertigen mord gewisse
gesetze erlauben um menschliche
handlungen
deshalb hat mich seine reaktion verstört
da sprach ein politiker kein tief
mitfühlen der vater wenn man sagt das
hätte mein sohn sein können sind das
schwerwiegende worte
da geht es um die familie also um das
kostbarste damit treibt man kein
politisches spiel mit manipulierenden
worten da geht es um herz und seele um
leben und tod
93 haben sie das buch geschrieben racers
damit würden sie schlagartig berühmt sie
wurden weltberühmt mit diesem buch
sie wurden auch eingeladen von präsident
clinton den damaligen us präsidenten ins
weiße haus sollten beraten in fragen die
mit rassismus zu tun haben
das ist ja eigentlich ein buch in dem
sie gesagt haben ich möchte mal
darstellen die es eigentlich um den
rassismus bestellt ist im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert in us
amerika mich würde interessieren was hat
sich seither verändert wenn sie 1993
gesagt haben race machos wir müssen
genauer hingucken
wir sind jetzt 20 jahre später was hat
sich verändert
eine wunderbare frage zuerst einmal
hatte ich natürlich einen größeren
konflikt mit präsident clinton wie ich
auch einen mit präsident obama hatte
denn bill clinton unterzeichnete ein
wohlfahrts gesetz das die staatliche
sozialhilfe für die armen kappte und er
verabschiedete das sogenannte drei
verstöße gesetz das zu einer zunahme von
massen inhaftierungen führte drittens
unterhalte er den glass steagall act der
zwischen investmentbanken und
geschäftsbanken unterscheidet deshalb
hatte ich einen riesen konflikt mit
klienten und war natürlich im weißen
haus nicht mehr bekommen
die inhaftierung von ganz ganz vielen
menschen vielleicht kann sie dazu noch
etwas sagen weil ich glaube das ist ein
phänomen das wir hier nicht so viel
diskutieren will clinton verabschiedete
gesetze über das zwingende strafmaß wie
gehst du eine tat oder besser ein
verbrechen musst du eine gewisse anzahl
jahre zwingend verbüßen
[Musik]
wie gehst du ein zweites verbrechen
musst du womöglich lebenslängliche
einsetzen
und wieder sind arme menschen betroffen
nicht wallstreet banker wie viele
bankmanager kamen nach der
finanzkatastrophe 2008 ins gefängnis
kein einziger wie viele verbrechen
werden an der wallstreet begangen
marktmanipulation insiderhandel betrug
er kommt ins gefängnis ein armer wird
mit marihuana oder kokain erwischt und
muss dafür hinter gitter
unter clinton wurde dann das zwingende
strafmaß beschlossen ein straffälliger
muss also ins gefängnis manchmal für
mindestens sieben jahre seit 37 jahren
lehre ich auch in gefängnissen momentan
unter richtig im rover gefängnis in new
jersey 150 männer
wir lesen platon augustinus und anderes
zwei drittel von ihnen sitzen wegen
weicher drogen sieben jahre zehn jahre
15 jahre
doch wenn vertreter der elite verbrechen
begehen wird keiner dafür belangt wir
gehen da sehen sie wie falsch und
amoralisch das strafsystem in den usa
ist wenn es um arme und arbeiten der
menschen geht das macht mich sehr wütend
gehen wir zurück zur frage was hat sich
verändert seit 19 93
da wollten sie nämlich gerade etwas
darüber erzählen problematisch finde ich
dass ich nicht genug verändert hat wie
schon unter clinton haben wir auch unter
obama eine neoliberale regierung was
meine ich mit neoliberalen ich beobachte
drei grundlegende tendenzen finanzierung
realisierung militarisierung die drei
gehen hand in hand finanzierung durch
die großen banken vor 25 jahren gegen
mehr als 25 prozent der gewinne an
banken
heute heißen sie fast 45 prozent der
gewinne ein
was bedeutet das für eine
kapitalistische gesellschaft auf
künstliche weise wird viel kapital und
reichtum geschaffen ohne dass dabei
produkte generiert werden
im alten finanzmarktkapitalismus gab es
wenigstens autos und andere handelsgüter
die von arbeitern produziert wurden
heute werden die großen geschäfte oft in
geheimen abgewickelt wenige haben
einblick es gibt keine transparenz auf
kosten der arbeiterklasse werden hoch
oben milliardengewinne gemacht
unter präsident obama bekommt ein
prozent der top-verdiener 95% des
gewinnwachstums
in den usa besitzen bereits ein prozent
der bevölkerung 42 prozent des vermögens
in nur 42 prozent
das ist oligarch autokratisch keine
demokratie kann mit einer so gigantisch
wachsende vermögensungleichheit
überleben
zum glück hat die occupy bewegung
protestiert und auch leute wie noam
chomsky michaels und barbara ehrenreich
die beunruhigt sind wegen dieser
situation in den usa amerikanischen
stimmen zu dem sie auch gehört beides
personen die sich auch einmischen wie
sie das tun wir möchten später nachher
gleich über über ihre philosophie
sprechen zuerst möchte ich mich noch ein
bisschen mit ihnen über ihre biografie
unterhalten die auch äußerst interessant
ist etwas was mich beschäftigt hat dass
ich ihre autobiografie brother lässt
gelesen habe ist dass sie beschreiben
wie sie geboren worden sind in oklahoma
später umgezogen nach sacramento und wie
sie dort in einem quartier aufgewachsen
sind das nur für schwarze personen
reserviert war sie waren sozusagen also
getrennt von den weißen menschen und sie
sagen im rückblick denken sie dass sie
eigentlich gut gewesen damals warum das
war eindeutig so für mich denn ich bin
wer ich bin weil mich jemand geliebt und
sich um mich gekümmert hat ich bekomme
überwältigende unterstützung und
bestätigung von meiner familie meine
eltern eileen und kräfte west meine
schwestern zins ja und cheryl cole oder
kräften und natürlich auch meine tochter
tun mein sohn clifton und mein enkel
keller
ich bekam auch unglaubliche liebe von
meiner kirche der charlotte church von
reverend will ipic und dekan hätten und
in sonntag schülerin kam am college und
später an der harvard university von
großen theoretiker john rawls von hilary
putnam stanley cavill robert music alle
diese großartigen professoren haben mich
geliebt und unterstützt auch retro die
an der princeton-universität der jetzt
am theologischen seminar ist
ich war also ein geliebtes kind
ich habe sehr viel liebe mit auf den weg
bekommen und mein leben begann auf der
schokoladenseite der stadt im schwarzen
ghetto
damals gab es dort viel liebe es war
keine holt wie man es heute nennt und
damit einen ort ohne liebe bezeichnet zu
viele junge menschen werden zu wenig
geliebt ich habe überwältigende liebe
gekommen ich gehöre zu einer caravan in
der liebe das ist die geschichte meines
lebens lässt er dann mit 13 jahren haben
sie aber etwas erlebt was sie sehr
geprägt hat sie schreiben dass sie im
sportunterricht einem schwimmlehrer
kennengelernt haben das war ein weißer
schlimm lehrer und er hatte ihnen
angebotenen das schwimmen beizubringen
und ging mit ihnen seines linken pole
eigentlich für weise reserviert war
sie sind ins wasser gesprungen und alle
weiße baden baden den gäste haben das
wasser sofort verlassen der swimmingpool
wurde ausgepumpt meer gepumpt das hätten
sie das wasser verunreinigt
wie sind sie mit solch einem erlebnis
umgegangen
ich dachte nur wie dumm dass diese
reisen brüder und schwestern so üble
vorurteile haben
ich war dort mit meinem leichtathletik
coach der auch ein weißer brot aber mit
er wurde sehr wütend alle konnte ich
nicht kategorisch über die weißen
herziehen
ich erlebte dass es auch anständige
weise gab die dieses verbrechen wie ich
ablehnte also fand ich ihre reaktion
einfach dumm
natürlich sitzen überlegenheitsgefühl
von weißen und männern antisemitismus
vorurteile gegen araber oder muslime
tief eigentlich ist es einfach nur dumm
und krankhaft man muss sich davon
distanzieren aber auch wissen dass es
sehr real ist das ist für mich ein sehr
intellektueller zugang mit 13 geist man
doch erstmal einfach verstört oder
gingen das nicht zu
ja aber das wurde mir beigebracht von
meinen eltern zum beispiel sie haben mir
gesagt
das dich nie von anderen so sehr
misshandeln dass du dich auf ihrer ebene
hinunter lässt und ihren hass wer wider
das ist mit das erbe von martin luther
king junior john coltrane und curtis
mayfield donny hathaway und theresa
franklin dass man auf hass mit liebe
reagiert nicht weil man masochistisch
wäre sondern weil sogar die hasser sich
ändern können man darf sie nicht anhand
von momentanen taten beurteilen sie
können sich wandeln und eine ganz andere
sicht auf die welt entwickeln aber man
darf nicht zulassen dass sie einen
schwächen und lehman man muss
weitergehen
tatsache ist die gelernte nie schwimmen
bis heute ist es der crew weil sie sagen
ich habe gelernt zu lieben ich habe
gelernt auch unter den widrigsten
umständen zu lieben was sie auch die
weißen menschen gerade sciences das
nennen
allerdings ich finde wir müssen
versuchen eine eigene gemeinschaft zu
schaffen auch in einer kalten und
grausamen das ist die voraussetzung
jeder hoffnung für unsere spezies nehmen
sie die mutter des schwarzen
jugendlichen emmett till als er von
feigen typen ermordet wurde sagte sie
ich verschwende keine minute mit hassen
sondern setze mich mein restliches leben
für gerechtigkeit ein
aus dieser tradition komme ich lasse
mich nicht auf das niveau von
schlägertypen und gangstern hinunter ich
anerkenne vielmehr dass sie meine brüder
und schwestern werden können wenn sie
sich bessern wollen
wenn liebe tatsächlich der motor ist um
eine erfolgreiche karriere hinzulegen
würde ich sagen sind sie tatsächlich
sehr geliebt worden wenn sie waren
unglaublich erfolgreich sind es nach wie
vor sie waren mit 29 jahren der erste
schwarze professor an einer der
eliteuniversitäten yale später haben
sich hart und princeton und sie gerissen
um sie gestritten
sie waren an diesen großen sogenannten
ivy league von diesen eliteuniversitäten
allen alle angestellt heute sind sie am
jun theological seminary in new york da
war auch dorothee sölle da war dietrich
bonhoeffer welche erinnerungen haben sie
an diese großen theologen
das leben hat es gut mit mir gemeint und
ich schätze mich glücklich dass sie zeit
mit so großartigen denken verbringen
konnte aber was mich betrifft geht es
mir nicht um erfolg
ich möchte vielmehr meinen idealen treu
sein weltlicher erfolg hat mich nie
beeindruckt denn erfolg ist heutzutage
eher ein synonym von gier als von
integrität man liebt das geld anstatt
die tugenden man besitzt viel wert
materielle spielzeug und vielleicht eine
trophäenschau und hat sich bestens mit
ungerechtigkeit und gleichgültigkeit
arrangiert auf gleichgültigkeit bringt
sogar engel zu meinen gleichgültigkeit
ist für den teufel heimtückische als der
teufel selbst wie der große bruder
joshua hentschel sagt es fragt sich also
von welchen werten lässt man sich leiten
und wie nutzt man seinen erfolg im kampf
für eine liebende gemeinschaft für
gerechtigkeit und demokratie
denn wir haben wenig zeit der weg von
der wiege zum sarg ist kurz das ist eine
aufsatzsammlung von ganz ganz wichtigen
texten texte die ihnen auch am herzen
liegen und da verkürzen sie ja
eigentlich auch diese idee von fon es
mit dem kampf für demokratie wie gehirn
in diese dinge zusammen
das beschreibt william james sehr gut in
seinem essay die empfindung der
rationale
glaube ist eine art von mut zuerst muss
man den mut haben kritisch zu denken und
damit gegen das denken der mächtigen
anzudenken
dann muss um den mut haben zu lieben und
den mut zu hoffen
außerdem geht es in jeder ernsthaften
abhandlung über glauben um liebe den
glauben hat zu tun mit
und diese ist eine form von loyalität
gegenüber etwas das größer ist als die
eigene person loyalität gegenüber einer
sache das muss nicht unbedingt eine
marke sein
heutzutage werden sachen auf marken
reduziert bei unserer zeit